Let me show you the passages that they
go to.
Okay, these are the passages. Okay, I'm
going to show it to you now for you, for
your benefit. You want me to answer for
you guys, right?
Ready?
For your benefit, right?
Yep. Exactly.
Precisely. You got it. Now, for their
benefit, I'm going to answer for you
guys, and you're going to see the
justice of God. You guys want an answer
for you? All right. If if man strikes
his male or female slave with a rod and
he dies at his hand, he shall surely be
punished. But if it be but if for a day
or two he is able to stand, no
punishment shall be taken, for he is his
property. Okay, now let's put things in
perspective.
And if men struggle with each other and
strike a woman with child so that she
gives birth prematurely, yet there is no
injury, he shall surely be fine as a
woman's husband will set for him. He
shall pay as a judges aside. Notice, if
you cause a baby,
a woman to prematurely go into labor
because you struck her, the baby dies,
you are to be put to death. But if
there's any further injury, then you
shall pay life for life, eye for eye,
tooth for tooth, hand for hand, foot for
foot, burn for burn, bruise for bruise,
wound for wound. Now watch the context.
And if a man strikes the eye of his male
or female slave and ruins it, he shall
let him go free on account of his eye.
And if he knocks out a tooth of his male
or female slave, he shall let him go
free on account of his tooth. All right.
Now, let's put this in perspective.
Okay. The lax talionus
because this guy's slow
isn't necessarily
talking about literally plucking a
person's eye that's plucked your eye.
The principle is that the punishment
cannot exceed the crime.
Are you with me? Eye for an eye means if
you took my eye, I don't take both your
hands, both your eyes and both your
feet.
That punishment is excessive. So the
spirit behind eye for an eye, tooth for
a tooth means the punishment
cannot exceed
the crime.
Are you with me there? The punishment
cannot exceed the crime.
Now, the Bible doesn't say to strike
your servant. It's saying if it happens
that you strike your servant. Injury is
done, right? So, you're going to be
punished.
But if he's not injured,
right? Then you're not punished. Not
because saying you could beat your
slave. It's saying in the case you did
and you injured him, you're going to be
punished. But if there's injury,
then let that be a lesson for you.
Right? And by property, the term
property doesn't have the same meaning
that you have today. I'm going to prove
to you when it says the slave is your
property. It's not to dehumanize your
slave. It means that he is under your
authority. He's within your possession
and you're responsible. Don't define
terms from your 21st century
perspective. You with me there [snorts]
to you property thinking oh something
that is
less valuable than a human like you know
my car. No no no that's not the
definition in that context. Property
means under your possession right
and therefore it's your responsibility.
Even with let's say your home your
property you're responsible for its
upkeep. You understand the principle?
You understand the principle here?
And I'm going to show you I for an eye
extends to the slaves. And here you get
an idea of what I for an eye means. It's
not literally taking an eye out. It
means the punishment cannot exceed the
crime.
And this illustrates it here. If I've
injured a slave, then they are free.
They're no longer slaves. But now watch
Leviticus 24:17-23.
Here's eye for an eye again. Now let me
tie it in. Okay. If a man strikes down
the life of any human being, he shall
surely be put to death. Notice any human
being, not classes, only free. Like 21
178 of the Quran. Any human being
includes even your slaves.
See how that works?
Are you learning?
Any human being includes your slaves
because they're human.
And by the way, notice this is in the
context of I for an eye. Same context as
Leviticus 24. So now when I read I for
an eye here
and then tied in with over here. Eye for
an I tooth and tooth extends even to
your slaves.
Okay everyone got this right?
If a man strikes down the life of any
human being not just free humans any
human being your slaves included shall
be put to death. And the one who strikes
down the life of an animal shall make
restitution for life for life. Meaning
since an animal does not have the same
value you do, you don't be put to death
for an animal, but you must restore that
animal. Restitution means you must now
give the owner of the animal an animal
in its place of the same value.
We got it.
Of the same value.
You get what restitution means? Because
an animal is not equal to the worth of a
human life. You don't put me to death
for killing your dog. But then I have to
replace your dog with a dog of equal
value. But if I were to put a human
slave to death, then I am to be killed
because it says any human being.
Okay, let's continue.
If a man injures his neighbor just as he
has done, so it shall be done to him.
Fracture for fracture. eye for eye,
tooth for tooth, just as he's injured a
man, so it shall be inflicted on him.
Now, does this apply only to free or any
human being? And besides, is your slave
not your neighbor?
Okay. Thus, the one who strikes down an
animal shall make restitution for it,
replace it with an animal of the same
value. But the one who strikes down a
man shall be put to death. only free
humans or any human being.
We catching this?
There shall be one standard of judgment
for you. It shall be for the sojourer as
well as the native. Meaning this same
law will apply to a foreigner who's not
ethnically an Israelite.
So you cannot discriminate between a
gentile and Israelite because if that
gentile lives in your midst, you treat
him as an Israelite, for I'm Yahweh your
God. Then Moses spoke to the sons of
Israel. They brought the one who had
cursed outside the camp and stoned him
with stones. Thus the sons of Israel did
just as Yahweh had commanded Moses.
Can you get any more fair than this? So
if I interpret this any human being
if I put him to death I'm to die
and injury for injury meaning the
punishment cannot exceed the crime
any human being would include
even slaves and Gentiles
that means when slaves are mentioned
males or females in the same context of
I for an
That shows you that slaves are not being
discriminated against, they're being
protected.
You get it?
And it also explains that eye for an eye
need not be literally literal meaning I
take out your eye. Meaning the
punishment cannot exceed the crime.
See the principle?
Because right here it says eye for an
eye.
And then it mentions if man strikes the
eye of his male or female slave and
ruins it, he shall let him go in free
account of his eye. Notice that the
taking of the eye results in the entire
person being set free and now being
treated as a free man. So is it
literally eye for an eye or is it a
principle?
The punishment cannot exceed the crime.
See, it's not as simple as saying, "Oh,
yeah, pluck his eye out."
And it shows you that this is
applicable
to the baby in the mother's womb
and to the male and slave because it's
telling you about a pregnant woman. If
you cause her to give birth prematurely,
but the baby is safe,
then you're only going to find the man
who caused her to go into labor pains
prematurely by striking her. But if the
baby's injured, eye for an eye, tooth
for a tooth, hand for hand, foot for
foot. But is it literal you pluck an eye
or is it talking about compensation?
Notice here it's being fined.
So the principle is your punishment
can't be greater than the crime. But the
punishment isn't literally an eye for an
eye, tooth for a tooth. It can refer to
a compensation
that will be equal, right,
to the eye or to the tooth or the hand.
But if it's murder, then that there is
no
ifs, ends, or buts. Put him to death.
So what is an eye for an eye for a
slave? They are to be set free. That's
eye for an eye. That's tooth for a
tooth.
You with me there?
See here? Tooth. See, I'm not lying. Eye
for an eye. Tooth for a tooth. Hand for
a hand. For a slave means set them free.
Eye for an eye, tooth for a tooth, hand
for foot for notice. If a man strikes
the eye of his male or female slave and
ruins it, he shall let him go free on
account of his eye. And if he knocks out
a tooth of his male, so it's telling you
what eye for an eye means.
The eye for the eye of a slave is their
freedom. The tooth for the tooth of a
slave is their freedom. That is the just
punishment. You need to set them free.
They're no longer your slaves. They're
now free humans.
Ron, you got to get out of here, buddy.
You were here earlier. Don't let me cuss
you out and throw you out of here.
Do you see? Makes sense, right?
This is why
if you do intensive research, you don't
find a recorded case in the Old
Testament where someone's eye was
plucked out because they plucked out
their neighbor's eye.
So, is it literally eye for an eye or is
it saying
the punishment
cannot exceed the crime? So if I do take
my servant's eye out, what is the eye
that I must now give in place of it?
Their freedom. What is the tooth that I
must give in place of the tooth being
knocked out? Their freedom.
We got it.